[Music]  on Sunday Kylie Jenner announced that  she gave birth to her first child a baby  girl with Travis Scott on February 1st  and on Monday a source told ET that a  name has been chosen naturally fans are  already speculating about what they  think the newborns name will be the most  popular theory butterfly butterflies are  just a part of the secrets of Kylie  Travis released a song butterfly effect  in 2017 that's rumored to be about the  reality star the two got matching  butterfly tattoos eight months ago which  might have been around the time they  discovered she was expecting the baby's  nursery is decorated with butterflies  and the 20 year olds been rocking lots  of butterfly jewelry others think Kylie  and Travis will name their baby girl  Mariposa which is the Spanish term for  butterflies the Beauty moguls new lip  kit is called Posey and Kylie's momager  Kris Jenner recently shared this pic of  the kit writing so cute  one of my favorite at Kylie cosmetics  shades  you